Einstein's general theory of relativity
involves wild kind of crazy sounding
ideas warps and curves in space and time
and to a scientist in the early part of
the 20th century these ideas were just
so foreign that to believe them to have
confidence that they might be correct
the theory needed to make a prediction
that could be confirmed through
experimental observations that Einstein
realized that there was a prediction
that came right out of the mathematics
of general relativity one that could be
confirmed by observations and the
prediction goes like this so Einstein
says look imagine that we're observing a
distant star when the earth is on this
side of the Sun the star's light will
just want a nice straight line
trajectory but then Einstein says
imagine that we're looking at that same
star six months later when the earth is
on the far side of the Sun he says look
if my ideas of warps and curves and
space are correct then that starlight
trajectory will go on a curved path as
it goes to the curved space-time region
near the Sun and that will mean that
observers on earth will think it will
seem to them that the position of the
star in the sky has shifted from this
location to this location
Einstein was able to calculate the
angular shift between these two
locations got a number 1.7 arc seconds
that in principle could be tested by
astronomical observations now the
challenge that you see right here is we
on earth need to be able to see that
star during the day while the Sun is out
the only way that you can do that is
during a solar eclipse when the moon
comes between the Sun and the earth and
blocked out the sun's light allowing the
distant stars to then be visible and Eve
there was a solar eclipse in 1919 and
during that solar eclipse a couple of
teams of English astronomers took
photographic plates of the distant stars
and indeed found that the positions of
the stars shifted by the angle that
Einstein predicted using general
relativity and that really was the
moment when the scientific community and
then the world took notice and realized
that Einstein had come up with a new
more accurate description of gravity a
new and more accurate description of how
the universe works